People: Good morning, Hank!
It's Friday.
John: Hank you just got said 'hello' to by
Josh Lewis, Holly Black, Cassie Clare and
the great Maureen Johnson.
As you can tell from the gray speckled walls
behind me, I am currently in an airport.
Actually, you're probably watching this in
the future, in which case I'm hopefully not
currently in an airport.
Unless you're one of these people, in which
case you're watching me in the present and
I am currently in an airport.
So I've been in New York for the last couple
days meeting with my publisher, Julie Strauss-Gabel,
and my agent, Jodi Reamer, to talk about The
Fault in Our Stars and all the wonderful things
that are happening, none of which I can tell
you about.
Do you know what I do, by the way, when I'm
in airports and my flight is delayed and I
have an hour to kill?
I sign The Fault in Our Stars!
I brought two thousand sheets to sign today.
It's a green pen day, in case you're wondering.
I get excited about, like, what the color
day is.
I wake up and one of the first thoughts I
have is, 'Is it a purple day?
I hope it's a purple day.'
But it's not.
It's always a green day.
Oh that would be a good name for a band...
Green Day...
So Hank because I spend about six hours a
day signing my name over and over again, I've
been thinking a lot about my signature and
its many inefficiencies.
I mean there's the obvious problem of the
complete illegibility of my signature, but
another disappointment about it is that it's
totally inconsistent.
Like sometimes it looks relatively good, like
this one, and then sometimes there are ones
like this one that are just you know, tragically
and irrevocably flawed.
And the weirdest part is that when I try to
explain to Sarah about these tragic and irrevocable
flaws in some of my signatures, she thinks
that I'm crazy.
She says that's the exact same signature as
any other signature, but let me tell you,
when you spend six hours a day looking at
your signature over and over and over again
in fifty-seven thousand iterations, you start
to notice the little things.
You know, like the amount of volume in the
J-Scribble and whether the hooble-dee-hoo
lines up with the whattidy-what in the J.
Which is not even to mention the variable
length of the gooble-de-gook over here at
the end end of my signature.
Also, this whosidy-what up here, sometimes
I don't even write that because my hand goes
off the paper.
It's a disaster!
Hank, I just had one of those "The people
at the airport think that I'm crazy" moments,
and it occurred to me that, uh, you probably
also think that I'm crazy.
I hope that I'm not suffering from Signing
Madness.
That's a disease, you know.
I made it up, but it's a disease.
Hank, let's go see if there's anything interesting
in the airport.
Look at all the free iPads, that's interesting.
Pizza is interesting.
A monument to dead sheep is kinda interesting.
Right, so funny story.
By the way, John from the future here, I'm
in a different airport, but anyway.
Right after I said that thing about how it's
sort of interesting to see a monument to a
dead sheep, a police office walked up to me
and said, "What are you doing?"
And I said, "I'm filming a monument to a deceased
sheep."
And he said, "Why are ya doin' that?"
and I said, "It's a really, really long story."
And then he just looked at me for a while,
and finally I said, "Is it illegal?" and he
said, "I don't know!"
And so I was like, "Well as long as we're
in this legal gray area, can I keep doing
it?"
and he said, "You probably shouldn't."
So thus ends the vlog.
I have to go get on a different airplane because
the previous airplane wasn't fun enough.
But Hank, I will see you on Friday!
Unless it is Friday, in which case I will
see you on Monday!
Sorry, I don't have my calendar with me!
Hi, it's John from the future future, I made
it back home, so that's good.
Quick P.S., in the great tradition of older
brothers, I have taken a cool toy that my
little brother enjoyed playing with and stolen
it.
I am referring, of course, to the YouTube
channel hankgames.
I have started a series of video's in which
I play FIFA while telling you stories of my
life.
So, for instance, if you click on my face
right now, you will be taken to a video where
I am playing as the Swindon Town Swoodilypoopers
while simultaneously telling you about how
I met and courted the Yeti.
So you can check that out there and if you
like it, subscribe, and thank- Hey!
Look, it's my calendar!
I missed you, calendar!